CAN'T CATCH
RIDING THERIED TO CLEAR.
GREENE KEPT IT FROM GETTINGNG
A HUGE OPPORTUNITY THERE, BROCK
NELSON, TO GET
THE ISLANDERS TURN IT OVER
WAHLSTROM TRYING TO BE BACK TO
COVER. -- AND THEY SCORE!
DOBSON'S SHOT 6'5" AND HE CAN'T
HUGHES.
AND HE SCORES!IS2-1FRONT,
HE'S COVERED.
LOOK HOW FORORDEVILS.
QUICK SPEED.
THAT'S W
HE SCORES!
THE FORMER DEVILS  LOOK UP.
WHAT'S INTERESTING THERE, NO
ISLANDERS WENT TO THE FRONT OF
THE NET.LL.
BRATT IS THERE.
NOW HAMILTON. MENTIONED  JAROS .
THE PUCK TAKEN BY
SHORT-HANDED.
SCORES!
FINALLY, THE
PLAY.
HE TRIES TO IT IS I'D.
HE WHIMS TO THE NET.
ZACHA WAS HANGING AROUND THERE..
COMING INTO THE ZONE.
WE'VE SEEN THEIR FIRST
SEVEN GAMES AT UBS ARENA.
>> AJ: SCHMID HAS BEEN
IMPRESSIVE INRD
TIME TONIGHT THEY WOULD HAVE WH
GOT THOSEIED UP.
PAGEAU.
ABLE TO MOVE.
OFF ICE WITH
AISLES.
>> AJ: GOOD CHANCES FOR THE
ISLANDERS.
THE PLAY IS GOING BACK AND
FORTH.
THIS ONE IS IT TAKEN BY
SIEGENTHALER.
STAYED ON IT.
NELSON.
AND THAT PUCK WOULDN'T  GET THET
FIRST GOAL.
HE'LL GET ANOTHERADVANTAGE.
AN ODD MAN RUSH.
WE
THIS  ANGLE, IT DID.
A GAME OF INCHES.HERE.
THE ISLANDERS ARE SHORT-HANDED.
15 SECONDS TO GO.